Let's keep our same ratio and this time look at using proportion and a table.
So, the number of dimes to the number of quarters is still two to three. But
this time I have 10 dimes in my hand. How many quarters am I holding? We could
solve this problem by extending our table. I could keep adding two dimes and
three dimes in each case. So I'd have 8 dimes, 12 quarters, and 20 coins in
total. And then 10 dimes, 15 quarters, and 25 in total. So if I add 10 dimes,
then that means I have 15 quarters. But, maybe there was a different way to see
this. If I take two dimes and if I multiply it by 5, then I also have to
multiply my quarters by 5. The same is true for the number of coins. I would
have 5 times 5, which is 25. Ratios often have a multiplier. We take our
original ratio and multiply it by a number. So to get from 2 dimes to 10 dimes,
we multiply by 5. So to get a 3 quarters to 15 quarters we also multiply by 5.
The number of the objects continue to increase, so I can have an n multiplier,
any number, and this would be 2n. 3n and 5n. These expressions represent the
number of coins for our dimes, our quarters, and our total, depending on our
multiplier.